dans un bar à vodka à la poire chez des consommateurs
ignorants de la France il ne peut pas se préparer il a
eu le cidre était heureux de montrer son devoir
bonjour applaudissements
il s'est réveillé yalla moch hala Casillas elle
plaide une bagarre Lynne city bhatia paresh nous avons rencontré Nora
Montalban elle  salami donc Dorothea musici
design scalpel
Zbyszko leadership pour Annette plus dans
la Paula Cooper observer un accord à la
conscience de Gemma venir à notre
algue jusqu'à un Illya - totosai de l'
arbre alors vu résolu
soldat
strident Benji oh mon Dieu nous nous sommes embrassés à tous
elle t'a agressé '  ll Danny man
appelle ça du velours seulement mangé et dis-lui
de me faire circuler dis polka Takeshi tu
encadres ton donateur
[Musique]
700 matraque
nous pourrions garder l'obsession
[Musique]
sauf Tillery Danny Suki FFXIII Kamini
asseyez-vous dans une ville numérique en canoë je veux
dire je dis  fête
ta mission si tu choisis de l'
accepter Je me demande si tu as déjà choisi de ne pas
[Musique]
la fin ou était craint pleure et le
sang sera sur ta main
les retombées de toutes tes bonnes intentions
toi  avait un choix terrible à faire à
Berlin
une vie sur des millions et maintenant le monde
est en danger c'est la mission de la CIA
s'il avait conservé le plutonium nous
n'aurions pas cette conversation
cela avait tendance à être mort oui ils le feraient
c'est le travail
[Musique]
tu ne comprends pas dans quoi tu es
impliqué tu dois t'en aller s'il
te plait ne me fais pas de codes pour toi combien de
fois les chasses le gouvernement l'a
trahi le désavouer le jeter de côté combien de temps
avant qu'un homme comme ça ait eu  assez
nous sommes
[Musique]
alors comment est-il oh tu sais toujours
là
quelles couleurs tu fais trouve qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas accrocher